una lluvia de misiles rusos en la
capital ucraniana en la tarde de este
miércoles las autoridades de kiev
informaron de ataques aéreos de Moscú
dejando muertos y heridos de documentos
Solo espero que todos estén bien pero vi
a la gente que están sacando del
edificio los que estaban heridos y no sé
si están vivos Pero espero que estén
bien
los bombardeos dañaron varias
estructuras eléctricas uno de los
objetivos públicamente declarados por
Moscú presuntamente para convertir el
frío y la oscuridad del invierno en un
arma estratégica Pero estos ataques
también complicaron la atención de
heridos en los hospitales que dependen
del generador de energía mientras esto
sucedía en kiev en Bruselas los
parlamentarios de la Unión Europea
declaraban a Rusia como estado
patrocinador del terrorismo avanzamos en
la resolución que reconoce a la
federación rusa como estado patrocinador
del terrorismo Alemania y chipre también
pidieron una detención inmediata de lo
que calificaron como bardeos terroristas
de Rusia Mientras que el presidente
ucraniano aseguró que van a recuperarse
de este masivo ataque y agradeció el
apoyo de los aliados
y el parlamento europeo finalmente
reconoció a Rusia como estado
patrocinador del terrorismo Gracias a
todos los parlamentarios y luego Rusia
demostró al mundo entero que esto es
cierto al usar 67 cohetes contra nuestra
infraestructura nuestra energía y gente
común
este miércoles Estados Unidos anunció
una concesión de 400 millones de dólares
adicionales en apoyo militar a Ucrania
con esta nueva ayuda Estados Unidos ha
concedido unos 19.700 millones de
dólares a Ucrania en asistencia de
seguridad desde que el presidente Joe
biden llegó a la casa blanca